yeah this is a town where you don't have
to travel very far but to meet people
who either work on the Balmoral estate
or certainly met the queen in the past
and really feel like the royal family
are neighbors because Balmoral is about
15 minutes drive away from here and on
that day that we saw the Queen's hearse
moving from Balmoral taking that very
long drive all the way down to Edinburgh
balloter in essence was the first town
that got to say a public goodbye to the
queen and we know that since her death
the king and queen consort have also
been spending a great deal of time up
here in Scotland yes of course no doubt
things for them to sort out up here as
would happen with the death of any
relative but also I think because this
is a place where they feel that they can
get away from it all where there is a
sense of seclusion but also today it was
important I think for them to meet as
many members of the community as
possible to really thank them for giving
the queen that spectacular send off you
might remember the pictures from the day
it was an absolutely beautiful day here
in the highlands and you really got a
sense of of why this area meant so much
to the queen as you mentioned around 500
members of Staff delivered the council
plans which had to kick into place
really quickly only three days basically
after the queen died but also I think
what for many really stood out that day
was those spontaneous moments so today
the king and queen console also met up
with a group of horse riders who had
come out with their horses and ponies to
line the route to say their own goodbye
and also you might remember that really
striking image around 40 tractors also
lined up along the route to give that
very unique guard of Honor as the queen
went by I spoke to those involved in in
both of those different ways of marking
the Queen's death and was told that it
really happened all very spontaneously
but was certainly marking the fact that
Countryside life was really important to
the queen what's also stood out today is
this is a really important two-way
relationship between people who live
around here and the royal family of
course King Charles now is going to take
over running the Balmoral estate so big
responsibilities for him when it comes
to the estate workers all the businesses
around here that rely on the Royal
household but also the locals could not
do any more to show that the king and
queen consort are always very welcome
spend time up here we know they've also
got their own property of Burke Hall and
locals showing that really this is still
a place that they can come they can
escape and get away from it all if they
need to